see this cute little vial here  that's crack rock cocaine the most  addictive form you think it's the  glamour drug of the 80s well that's the  point of this fronted little reminder it  can kill you and if you've got to die  for something this sure as hell ain't it  in the next few months the motion  picture industry and theater owners will  be bringing you a series of messages  like the one you just saw I don't think  anybody will miss the point the thrill  can kill the drug dealers need to know  that we want them out of our schools  neighborhoods and our lives and the only  way to do that is to take the customers  away from the product say no to drugs  and say yes to life support your local  drug pusher may tell you a little  something different about these drugs  and who you believe is up to you but  then again if you go ahead and try them  at least it won't be out of ignorance  just stupidity what would I do if  someone offered me these drugs  I tell them to take a hike